sera pas du tout le nouveau co vide mais
moi ça fait plus rock locaux vides parce
que faire moi qui ai un physique
avantageux
mais c'est vrai voilà c'est ça regardez
moi ça c'est mon capital
on peut pas voir ni avec ça casse le
mythe métropole non mais martin est bien
pourtant réussi grâce à ça on dira un
jour point frère andré c'est quoi ça ça
arrive avec ça arrive ça arrive ya des
cas
non la vérité mais
il faut se rappeler que 121 jours cela
disparaît donc on est quand même des
choses qui se tient à grésy et pour
l'instant on n'est pas dans mieux
flambées épidémiques on l'a été pour le
coc bidon avec quelques cas dans
différents pays visiblement c'est assez
peu contagieux mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelque chose qui a changé puisque avant
il y avait quelques cas comme ça tu vas
du singe en afrique et on n'a jamais eu
autant de cas qui émergent çà avait
perdu mais ce qu'on est vraiment courant
gilles verdez mois martin je les aime
beaucoup mais là vous êtes un rassurer
c'est à dire qu'encore une fois vous
minimisez regardez regardez le rouge par
toi le rouge partout tient plus à céder
sa place à
l'espagne qui dit on va sortir nos
vaccin contre la variole ces chaussées
chose le centre européen de prévention
et de contrôle des maladies qui les
attentions très jeunes enfants et
anciens aux femmes enceintes attention
personnes âgées peut-être faut-il
vacciner les soignants exactement on
panique et vous vous le dit tout va bien
martin ça va pas franchement non
500 qui fonctionne bien
nous vacciner vers les prochaines avec
sa décollecte on à éradiquer la variole
seydoux reprend exactement une stratégie
pour la variole du singe et remet donc
ça veut dire qu'on a des vaccins qu'on
ait encore on va le faire
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de quoi coller vaccin
actuel fonctionne très bien les vaccins
contre la variole accords existants
entre la variole qui sait qu'il ya des
nouveaux vaccins marc et fabrice des
mais quel
con utilisés dans les années 70 ce cas
les vaccins d'éradiquer la variole plus
des nouvelles générations avec cinq sont
sortis depuis qui fonctionne à 85 90 kg
5e génération de dax un toit c'est la
génération 80 ml
mais je veux tu connais martin le kili
les éditions pily
alors pour ceux qui
affectionnent logique ni quand même jean
claude philippe ce que dit la bible de
la peinture j 1 elle te dis la
transmission inter humaine étant
considéré comme faible la vaccination
antivariolique des sujets contact n'est
pas recommandée dans les régions
concernées le sucre canaris lanning le
père fouras pas tant que ça je voulais
me oui mais tu as bien compris tu avais
quelque chose de nouveau sur la valeur
et quelque chose devenu du même coup tu
proposes de vaccinés avec un vaccin donc
si j'ai bien compris qu'on ne connaît
pas parce que tu me parle forcément de
la chute du concept n'est pas tu vas me
dire qu'il y avait trois générations en
générations c'est le vaccin ivanek ce
qui va faire l'objet d'études y compris
pour la pro b pour la prévention de la
maladie chez l'homme en république
démocratique du congo 7 mai de milliman
accès pour la variole qu'est ce que le
est ce que le vaccin ivanek ça était à
sonner même son autorisation de mise sur
le marché est ce qu'il est si tu veux
parler de ces rites et non pas sur
efekta sur la prône pas la prophylaxie
des cas contacts
alexis déclare le problème est toujours
le même en réalité
il a raison sur un point c'est quoi ton
deux façons de deux façons d'aborder le
problème soit on laborde en se disant
effectivement il ya un truc là qui se
passe est vraiment grave pourquoi c'est
grave parce que ça se propage c'est ça
que du coup c'est d'autant plus grave
qu'on sait pas ce qui se propage c'est
ce qu'on se dit parce que régal un
élément important c'est que la variole
la variole du sein sont actuellement je
n'ai pas celle qu'on connaît
habituellement sakho les modes de
transmission manifester sa part rapports
homosexuels
ne correspond pas à ce qu'on documente
dans la littérature en général sur cette
question l'épidémie de 2003 aux états
unis n'étaient correspondait pas à sa
place elle se sent que c'est un nouveau
truc quoi en tout cas il se passe un
truc mais si
tu disais ce seul kobe
tu disais la même chose dont j'ai
retrouvé tout d'un coup la maison jeté
par qu'on accole ma cause de vous
[Applaudissements]
mario
mais c'est vrai
moi je dors plus la nuit moi mais de dix
noms ni par contre effectivement
aujourd'hui qu'il faut être ce sur quoi
il faut être clair c'est que la
transmission interhumaine reste a priori
faible et que nous ne pouvons tirer
aucune conclusion de ce qui se passe
actuellement au cma mais quand même ça
c'est donc quand marc baldy qu'il faut
vacciner les cas contactez martin parle
comme d'habitude car j'ai envie de dire
effectivement pour lui même et par lui
mais non mais fabrice c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est là aussi de s'assurer
qu'ils connaissent ils visitent ce qui
nous était pas du tout la retint pas du
tout ça s'appelle agence américaine
north american airlines peut-être mais
c'est terrence malick est elle le parle
parle aussi bas actuels enfin elle l'a
dit organise 3 mais n'en parle pas pour
rêver de michele agence européenne le
cilicie européen lui ne dit pas ça et
samedi il ya eu de vraies bonnes équipes
l agence européenne mais ça peut être un
site ici
il faut lire de temps en temps afin
que tu dis tu verras que quand tu lis un
peu comme ça ici là les éléments y
l'épidémie s'agir comment quand tu
connais pas qu'est ce que tu fais en
médecine quand tu as un truc arrive tu
sais pas bien ce qui se passe qu'est ce
que tu fais tu appelles ton que je
regarde tu regardes c'est secondaire
tu crois quoi
toi ce que tu commence par faire c'est
vouloir injecter un truc à propos duquel
je viens de te dit récemment qu'il te le
dis c'est qu'il est fondamentalement wa
regarda h alors premiers éléments ici
dit si elle te dis que les vaccinations
l'encré vaccination pour le coup sûr
disponibles les cas contact à haut
risque deux vrais should be
doit être considéré la chose huit heures
après une évaluation du bénéfice-risque
h au louis ii devra être la chaîne se
transforme en doit être donc là c'était
oui mais
comment ont effectivement baissé c'est
quand même et reste que le public sache
quelque chose à propos de la vaccination
la chaise écoutez bien ce que dit la
chasse c'est important je regarde donc
elle dit qu'il faut vacciner avec un
contact mais elle adaptera sept
recommandations préliminaires c'est
qu'il ait aucun sens et les producteurs
de la
direction dans la fonction des nouvelles
en
matière écoute moi je trouve martin en
fonction des nouvelles données
épidémiologiques et cliniques
disponibles je comprends rien attendre
de disposer écoute moi prochainement je
dois bien pressés sur les modes de
transmission interhumaine pour les cas
actuellement défini donc on ne sait pas
comment ça se transmet les données de
suivi de l'épidémie donc on ne sait pas
g avec l'épidémie les deux mis en vie
réelle complémentaires relatives à
l'efficacité tous les groupes
antivariolique de troisième génération
lui
on ne sait rien et tu viens de le voir
ne sais pas regarde ta vaccination des
cas contacts elle engage martin blaché
parce que ma table h et a décidé que
c'est comme ça mais la dernière fête
martha de la chaîne d'essayer quelque
chose c'est qu'elle treize années cas
était parfaitement inoffensif tendu
trois ans plus tard
[Applaudissements]
sa division donc commandes à éradiquer
la variole dans le monde pourquoi tu me
paraît très récemment on a éradiqué
80 alors juste que je suis vous dire
comme on dit avec evra gueule par deux
moyens d'abord parce que il ya
effectivement la vaccination il ya
contribué mais d'aucuns médocains aucun
séga sakho a
ensuite comparé la variole du singe au
demeurant dans sa forme actuelle à la
variole
mart a dit quelque chose marche était
vaccin
effectivement il m'a dit voilà martin
blachier deux ans après quand tu te
crois que ça fait combien de temps que
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas de questions n'a pas
pourquoi la bible de l'infectiologie te
dis calmement des consignes et
redit mais tu contre d'italie twain
qu'on savait pas que c'était un nouveau
départ en retraite à temps martin vous
dit quelque chose il vous dit je ne sais
pas ce que c'est mais je sais ce qu'il
faut faire je ne sais pas ce que c'est
mais les skis je sais pas ce qu'il faut
faire c'est pas ce que c'est mais joseph
on commet une folle lutter contre ça il
se met ça dans un sac et on martin
tu ne sais pas quelle maladie je sais
même pas ce que tu défends objectif
c'est ça va ainsi de préco alors ce à
quoi tu veux parce que martin le haut
conseil de santé publique on s'en fou
qu'est ce que tout agent recommande
alors on fait rien mais martin sait rien
faire et on a moyen je le sais
entre toi et moi tu prends la
responsabilité entre toi et moi la
dernière fois qu après la responsabilité
de quelque chose matin
sinon seraient tombés d'accord sa [ __ ]
martin c'est la dernière fois que tu as
pris la responsabilité de quelque chose
c'était sur ce plateau de dire que
astrazeneca ne serait jamais suspendu
ouais il a été cité à deux jours plus
tard alors chut
utiliser le vaccin sera été acquitté de
sa mutation
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas mais
je sais tout à l'heure que la différence
entre 21h et moi que se situe à l'est et
c'est que moi je ne demande à personne
de me croire à partir de là chez lui
martin mais tu demandes un document le
jour de se croire que tu t'es planté sur
toute la ligne de touche en plus alors
on fait quoi
fabrice on comprend pas toi c'est
dangereux c'est pas dangereux alors en
compte pour l'instant
pas c'est quoi à l'instant au regard des
données ça ne semble pas dangereux même
s'il ya une interrogation sur la
question de savoir pourquoi ça se
transmet via les relations sexuelles
entre
public disent qu'il faut faire il te dis
qu'il faut isoler isoler les malades à
isola 2000 faut isoler les malades ça
c'est important lorsqu'il est disait
déjà en 2010 juste ce qu'il fallait
faire d'ailleurs ce qu'il fallait
effectivement réduction d'une
transmission de l'animal à l'être humain
ça sera les réductions de transmissions
interhumaines
il faut éviter que la
rs6 avoir démarré la fabrique de la
favela tu nous ressent les jeux
encore un truc on y attend et là ce
n'est pas le droit sur un plateau à quoi
tout le monde sort du comité
explique j'explique pourquoi on gère la
variole en isolant les vaccinant
l'entourent
c'est vrai qu'avec son poulain 2001 ça
fout d'addario il est
normal que là on aimerait savoir on voit
que les cas il y en a de plus en plus
qu'est ce qui va se passer mais qu'est
ce qu'on va faire est-ce qu'il est
personne ne sait alors on fait quoi
alors on sera plus mais sinon notre
commande de dix faits et bien pour
l'instant continuer à observer c'est ce
que dit le haut conseil de santé
publique et on continue de voir ce qu'il
attend
le risque de transmission interhumaine
reste relativement faible qu'est ce qui
se passe pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des cas
effectivement ce qu'un peu qu'on en ait
pas sansfaçon on s'est aimés mais
comment vous tue qu'on sache mais parce
qu'on verrait on sait les prévisions non
adhésion méditer quand il a dit vous
vous plantez encore une fois quand on ne
sait pas on dit on ne sait pas elle
s'appelle l'honnêteté mais quand on sait
pas on cherche et quand on sait là et
qui chie en concert bassi alors non pas
en baissant leurs noms ils poseraient un
questionnement on sait pas personne ne
peut dire je ne dirais pas ici qui ne se
passe rien alors dirais pas ça ça peut
être ça devenait que pour l'instant il y
a personne ne sent que ça va durer
scarlett une galère cette affaire mais
ça peut toujours tout une grippe peut
être une galère une épidémie de grippe
peut être une galère est ce que ça va
mais comme un bon salaire genre qu'ovide
non parce que la transmission est trop
fait donc il y aura pas d on vole
épidémique la ccc les soins sont
nécessaires et tout fait mais on essaie
déjà vous faire un écolier qui sont
présents pour éradiquer cette variole du
singe comme on à éradiquer la variole
étant on veut faire disparaître ce truc
ça arrive alors qu'avant non on en
attendait pas parler c'est ça
potentiellement changer en fait on sait
pas donc là dessus fabrice a raison et
sexy trois heures juste pour dire sa
part être qu effectivement sais pas de
quoi tu leur donnes à 2 minutes 20
minutes fabrice arrête neuilly peu paris
vers les séparent mais non mais non
merci pas
arriver ici et recommencer son cinéma
qui fait du cnca leurs vidéos nous voilà
vaccination signé les cas contacts ou
que celle ci explique la recommandation
j'ai droit commendation jeu visiblement
quand j'explique que c'est plus clair
que d'actualité finir par recommandation
d'un kilo qui 2 qui fixe une technique
ma famille
[Applaudissements]
sa musique aux attentes at on pas
positif et c'est tout ce que je voulais
pas de cela on va effectivement se
mettre d'accord a besoin de trop pour je
l'accepterai pas non mais c'est vrai
pour toi hein je retire je me dis que je
m'excuse mais mais les classes et un mot
c'est ma
nation est ce que si les recommandations
de martha blachier
non c'est la convention c'est d'accord
qu'elle lui a recommandé de vacciner les
cas contacts comment qui a fait ça lasse
en utilisant les vaccin antivariolique
elle laisse
les vaccins qui sont sur le marché des
vaccins qu'on a les vaccins de troisième
génération il accepte rugby sport voilà
les gars
non mais c'est sa technique comme il ne
sait pas quoi répondre il va vous merci
t on
c'est faux je la prends comme national
d'akanda sc2 par action du type la
chaîne fait de la politique parce que
bien conscients de la richesse
aujourd'hui martin tu as raison de dire
ça mais je t'ai lui quand même les
limites de cette recommandation sont
dans l'île se rappelle que l' agence
européenne elle est beaucoup moins
catégorique alors tu peux te fie à la
chaise quand on a envie en nous mettant
et c'est gratuit on en met en
marche j'aime toujours le même on a tous
les toits de moi
le même problème sur ce plateau chacun
vient avec son avis personnel fait peur
aux gens mais est-ce que ça fait peur de
dire
voir martin ce qui fait peur c'est ta
façon de parler
expliqué fabrice les français qui n'ont
rien a besoin de réponses donc toi tu
nous rassure sur la variole tu penses
qu'à pas de quoi fouetter un chat non je
pense qu'il n'y a pas ça va pas du sénat
rien à voir avec ce qu'on vit donc pour
répondre à votre question ça n'a rien à
voir et que kevin néanmoins qu'on a une
stratégie qui a prouvé son efficacité
pour les poudres supprimer la variole
qui est un fléau mondial pourquoi on
l'utiliserait parti de dire quelque
chose qui vient d'arriver dire pourquoi
on a tous envie de laisser progresser
personne a menacé ce socle à progresser
c'est comme si tu disais et coûteux on a
un vaccin contre une maladie qui
fonctionne c'est pas même maladie non va
utiliser le même vaccin je suis désolé
mais c'est pas vrai c'est que tu dis
c'est pas une honte pourquoi tu compares
la variole la variole du singe mais
passer de la vanne maladie c'est un
cousin un cousin un coût
de fonctionnement
de variole du singe aujourd'hui non mais
oui ou non fabrique fabrice fabrice
hamaide marc bellemare et avec marseille
le problème est celui varitek béthunois
l'on voit si je peux dire des prénoms
moi je veux dire je vais recommencer
comme toujours soit je viens pour
apporter des données qu'ils aimeraient
voir
les choses
c'est pas du bus
soit effectif il a dû ce que le boss ça
je suis en
train de m'en fais pas trop cette par
approximations qui ne sont pas normales
après il a le droit de se convaincre de
ce que c'est normal mais néanmoins venir
préparer la variable variole du singe
c'est exigeant une erreur de dix jours
il existe deux vaccins
mais tu fais exprès de dire n'importe
quoi tu cherches embrouiller les jeux en
fait mais si toi qui cherchent un blanc
et un truc et ça fait une heure que tu
essayes d'embrouiller les gens en quoi
je suis pas il ya quelque chose de
simple les gens comprennent guère qu'un
vaccin qui existaient pour une maladie
qui a disparu tu es d'accord avec ça et
les données qu'on a montrent que ça
marche sur ce sur ce virus qui allait
reculer daniel
gilles agniel capture
à la traversée le choléra la grippe
espagnole la guatémaltèque
toujours et elle est toujours là vivent
la lutte variole bah ça ne se voit pas
non mais j'ai daniel qu'est ce que tu
vois disais que j'ai vu un truc qui m'a
fait peur par rapport à la transmission
vous avez l'air de dire que vraiment
c'est très court il ya quand même manger
c'est en espagne il ya eu une
quarantaine de personnes qui ont qui ont
eu cette variole du singe bon après
s'être avait après avoir été dans un
jacuzzi ou dans un salon bon ça ça fait
donc est ce que c'est vrai ce qu'on en
sait
rien et les
attendait benhalima des infos
apparemment été dans le sauna
depuis hier où il y avait des relations
sexuelles
bah ouais
baptisé santé et donc c'est un sauna ou
rejoignez bon et voilà ont des relations
sexuelles d'accord mais met justement en
fait c'est même le faire est ce que est
ce que les gens doivent avoir un enfant
avec le préservatif est ce que c'est
vrai ça c'est la vrai que les français
aujourd'hui parce qu doit arrêter le
sauna
notamment avec ce signal qui est arrivé
effectivement c'est dans ces
circonstances là que visiblement il ya
eu la plupart des infections donc on dit
contacts rapprochés pour l'instant c'est
essentiellement effectivement des hommes
au mot bisexuel ça pourrait être un
rescapé nom
aurait laissé finir mal a encore
qualifié ça de rester parce qu'on sait
pas exactement encore le mode de
transmission et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'avait pas vu avant que c'est
quoi alors qu'avant c'étaient des cas de
gens qui avaient été en contact avec des
rongeurs qui l'avait attrapée en afrique
vraiment négatif en tonneaux
35 à nyala s'allonger
mais vu les gars
tranquille en train de cannes une
belette là
la merde en 2010 rongeurs ayant croix
rouge au premier étage véritable sont
faits tout en tout cas des tâcherons
genre
nouveau dans cette histoire c'est la
contamination par voie sexuelle était
quand même pas le mode de contamination
que nokia savoir c'est quoi le code mode
de contamination chez andré sa droite de
contamination semble c'est quoi être
c'est bien rapports homosexuels
mais la majorité
virtuel ça pas de sens grise mine cette
séquence est une transmission par les
flux corporelle sa sixième sacre
d'accord mais c'est un homme avec
alassane en mai qu'une femme c'est une
femme avec une barbe pour
l'instant il semble donc c'est un
créneau que ce soit des hommes avec des
hommes à
lui cas de transmissions interhumaines
généreusement génétiquement on est des
hommes tout court donc n'y a pas de
raison que ce soit les hommes à ne pas
être d'accord je
n'ai pas de raison fait-on a pas de
raison je dis attention sur le fait que
ce soit la peau d'un homme avec c'est un
homme qui fasse que l'inde puisse
transmettre le virus à un autre homme et
c'est ça qui est observé
ces mêmes rapports avec ses potes ont
jamais les femmes pratiquer la sodomie
aussi un
la raison est la raison et la médaille
des justes sans doute fait moncler en
plus il fait chaud on comprend pas bien
c'est pourquoi est ce qu on dit que
c'est dans les communautés homosexuelles
ça c'est le début mais ça c'est ça me
ravit
c'est bon mais il ya cette raison en
fait il pas que les hommes de plus de 50
ans donc un risque c'est vrai c'est
parce qu'il a gagné avec ce fait là on a
arrêté à bayonne dans les années 80
l'unc effectivement les hommes de 50 ans
aujourd'hui ont été vaccinés avant
ouais c'est avec 5
ça voudrait dire qu a priori toutes les
personnes qui ont qui on
s'entend sentent sont plus ou moins
couvertes dans l'annexé 7 ou encore vous
êtes enfin mais enfin je veux qu'on peut
dire ça à martin tu nous expliquer tout
à l'heure que c'est pas même virus que
la variole c'est ça ça tu es tout seul
tu es tout seul sans histoire là c'est
tout seul tout seul
sentiment que ça marchera capable de ne
pas reproduire les mêmes erreurs tu a
procédé par affirmation tout le temps il
ya des études qui le montrent oui une
fois il ya des études dans pma
être humain s'est fait en afrique nas et
qui montrent qu'effectivement ça utilise
le risque d'être infecté l'avoir été
vaccinés contre la balle sur la variole
du singe voici la variole du singe la
variole du singe de l'isc dit je te lis
que 18 sont
il a
dit exactement chose que moi
on nage en eau vive arbustes ou
pas c'est qui ces émissions qui cesse
d'avoir des vaccins at on dit il est
primordial de comprendre les voies de
transmission actuelles de la maladie
avant d'envisager de passer commande
pour ces vaccins troisième génération
cette utile d'avoir des vaccin
antivariolique mais ceux qui pressent
actuellement c'est de qui ça prendre les
voies de pénétration de maladie qui se
transmet généralement de l'animal à
l'homme dorénavant ils semblent se
transmettent de magna qui m'aide à me
sentir s'était caché sous le menton
précaution voilà quelqu'un
qu'effectivement on dit qu'il faut
prendre des mois fédérer c'est du solide
et sa religion c'est qui ce n'est pas la
voir mais
je sais ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'on dit
c'est
une phrase 30 secondes martin il faut
s'inquiéter ou on dit nico book non il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas d'inquiétudes
majeures ça n'a aucun rapport avec le co
vide on a pas tous être confinés a donc
je peux aussi la galoche des rongeurs
allez vas-y chasse galerie on peut y
aller enquête pourquoi fabrice en 10
secondes moi je me suis jamais inquiété
espérons que ça a commencé l'inquiétude
était très mauvaise non sur son rapport
l'inquiétude est très mauvaise qui
génère je ne sais pas ce que sera cette
maladie mais je sais ce que j'ai à dire
l'inquiétude et manie bien là bas vous
êtes d'accord du vrai de quoi merci